[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSEPH KAVA: Thank you
for coming and attending
this session.
You've chosen the best
session at Next to sit in on.
My name is Joe Kava.
I'm the vice president of
Global Data Centers at Google.
What that means is that I
helped to lead the teams that
are responsible for the
end-to-end lifecycle
of our data centers, from the
very beginning stages of site
selection and location strategy
to procuring all of our energy
contracts, including our
renewable energy, to design,
construction, and full
operations of the data
centers all around the world.
I've been at Google
just over 11 years,
and have had the pleasure of
working with amazing people
and seeing incredible
technology evolve.
So today, I'm going
to try and give you
a little bit of a insider's
view into our data centers, what
makes them special,
what I really appreciate
about our data centers.
And as a clue, it has
a little something
to do with sustainability.
You probably saw this on their
screen as you entered the room.
We're using a tool,
first time at Next.
It's called Dory.
It's an internal
tool that we use
at Google for all of our
large meetings like this.
So feel free to open
up the tool on the app.
And you can submit questions
and upvote other questions.
And I'm going to try and
leave time here at the end
so that we can address them.
And we'll also have mics
open for live questions,
if you'd like.
OK, so let's start with a little
bit of an examination of what
do you need from a data center.
Well, if you're like me, and
I suspect most of you are,
you need your data center
to be very high performance.
You need it to be
highly available.
You need it in places
where you need to be.
You need it to be
extremely reliable.
It needs to be ultra secure.
And if you can wrap that up
with a bow of sustainability,
then you've got something that
is truly meeting all your needs
in a data center.
Since the earliest days
of when I got to Google,
and actually long
before I was there
for about two
decades now, Google
has been the leaders in
ultra-high performance
computing systems.
One of the things that impressed
me when I first arrived
was that, even as innovative
as the data centers were,
I remember the very first day
that I was at a Google data
center, and everyone
wonders what a data
center is like at Google.
I did too.
When I got there, I
was tracing the path
of the electrons in my mind
and I was just shaking my head.
And my manager asked
me, is something wrong.
And I said, no, it's just
so obvious I don't know
why everyone isn't doing it.
But what impressed
me most is that
no matter how good
we're doing, we always
believe we can do better.
So we have a relentless
focus on innovation
and constant
technology evolution.
So ultra-high performance,
what does that mean?
Well, for us, it means
that we don't rely on just
off-the-shelf components.
We design and build almost
every part of the stack,
custom built for us for
ultra-high computing ultra-high
efficiency, at the
price and performance
that we need it to be.
So this is everything from our
custom designed, high voltage
substations that are on the
campus of all of our data
centers, to the
servers themselves,
the racks that
the servers go in,
the custom designed
cooling solutions
that those racks mate
to, to even the way we
operate the cooling plants.
I'll touch on that
a little bit more.
But as I mentioned,
it truly is just
a relentless focus on
continual improvement
and constant innovation.
So as I mentioned, these
are built for Google.
There's no unnecessary
components in our servers.
They're stripped down,
just ultra-high-performance
computers.
This reduces vulnerabilities.
As you know, we have a very,
very strong focus on security.
So all of our servers have
our built-in Titan chip,
from the time that
they're manufactured
for us to our specifications.
And that Titan chip is
helping to secure every server
throughout its entire
lifecycle at Google.
All of our services are
dynamically allocated.
We talk a lot about this.
Our Borg system, which we
have been using internally
at Google since
the earliest days,
that eventually became
the orchestration layer
for all of our containers.
And so we are constantly
provisioning and upgrading
and redoing our infrastructure.
And since we're constantly
upgrading and changing,
it has to be very
flexible and adaptable.
So we put a high
priority on optionality.
I'll talk a little bit
more of what that means.
Has to be extremely
efficient, ability to scale.
And our data centers also are
compliant with the Open Compute
Program, the racks that
are available through that.
So why is that important?
Well, it just means that we're
leveraging the rest of the data
center ecosystem as well, not
just relying on what we do.
We also have our own teams that
are staffing the data centers,
in particular our
hardware operations teams
that are there 24/7
at our data centers.
They're doing all
of our deployments,
maintenance, upgrades, repairs
of all of the hardware,
all the servers, storage, and
network in the data centers.
They're there in real time,
so they respond very quickly.
They have all the
tools necessary to make
their job very efficient.
And they are highly reliable
and do this all the time.
So we're not relying on an
SLA with a service provider
to come in and service
the data centers.
We do that ourselves.
Since I've been at
Google, we have constantly
been innovating in cooling.
Why is that important?
Well, data centers
consume a lot of energy.
And in a data center, one of
the largest overhead components
is related to the air
conditioning, or the cooling
of the data center.
So we have innovated
our cooling systems
about every 18 months since the
time that I've been at Google.
We've used a variety
of cooling techniques.
We use seawater.
In Finland, we bought
a paper mill, turned it
into a big data center campus.
And it actually was sitting
right on the Gulf of Finland.
So we were looking
at that water that
was about 14 degrees Celsius
all year round and said,
we can use that.
So that data center is
100% cooled by seawater.
We use reclaimed and
stormwater in a data center
in the southeast of
the United States.
We built a stormwater
capture and reuse system.
So we're cooling the data
center with stormwater there.
In Belgium, were
sited right next
to a big industrial
shipping canal.
So we used the industrial
shipping canal water.
The point is, you see
where I'm going with this.
We don't have a
cookie cutter design.
one-size-fits-all model.
We optimize the designs
of the data center
for that specific location,
for the environment
that it's working
in to make most
use of the natural
resources that are there.
So that's what you need
from a data center.
But you also have to consider
where the data centers are.
You need them in
the right locations.
They have to meet you
where you need to be.
So we have a very large
footprint of data centers.
We have 16 global campuses.
When I talk about a
campus, a campus to us
is typically hundreds of
acres with many buildings,
many data center buildings
on each campus, all connected
by one of the world's largest
most high performance public
networks available.
We have 19 regions
for our cloud compute.
We have 58 availability
zones there.
134 points of presence.
We are in over 200
countries around the world,
all interconnected with hundreds
of thousands of miles of fiber,
including 13 of our
own sub-sea cables,
making us really the largest
overall compute infrastructure
of any of the major players.
So even long before
cloud computing
was a large business
for us, we had
been building this
infrastructure for a couple
decades to service
our own needs,
to service Gmail and search
and ads and all of the YouTube
and all of the Google services.
So we have been building
this infrastructure.
And we learned how
to scale and we
learned how to build efficiently
for our own internal needs.
What that means is that we
have eight products currently,
that each are serving over a
billion active customers a day.
It's a lot of learning
that came with that.
And all of that gets
applied to Google Cloud.
So they're benefiting
from two decades
of learning how to
scale, how to build,
how to do things
hyper-efficiently.
So where are our data centers?
Well, we have data center
campuses on four continents--
North America, South America,
Asia, and Europe, of course.
We pick the sites based on
a rigorous time-tested site
selection criteria.
We take input from our
internal customers.
Cloud is one of our
largest customers
now, dictating a
lot of where they
want to be to
serve the customers
and meet you where you are.
So with that, we look for things
that we can more or less build
into for the next decade or so.
So our strategy is that
we want to find sites
that we can be building at and
building up for about 10 years
or more.
There is a long
list of criteria.
A lot of people always ask me,
how do you choose a data center
site.
And if I were to quote the head
of our site selection team,
he would probably say, it's more
or less the art of compromise.
Because there is
no one site that
meets 100% of every single
thing we would love,
so we try and find
the best compromise.
But what that means is that--
like this site here
is in Belgium--
we wind up with a
large parcel of land
that we can build multiple
data centers on for many years
to come.
And that gives us
access to our customers,
gives us access to a
workforce, gives us
access to high quality
fiber, and, more importantly,
every day gives us access
to renewable energy.
This particular data
center is in Iowa.
This is in our central region.
This is the first part of
the parcel that we developed.
This part of the
parcel is 300 acres.
The overall site is about
three times that size.
If you were to
measure this out, this
fits about 235 American
football fields
on this part that's
the developed part.
We have another two parcels
that we could develop
that are equally this large.
You'll see in the foreground
here that that small building?
That's a one-story data center,
that building is about a third
of a mile long.
And then behind it,
you see the data center
that's a little taller?
That's a two-story data center,
also a third of a mile long.
And then the ones
that you see that are
being built behind that?
Those are four-story
data centers.
Also will be about a third of
a mile long when completed.
The amount of capacity
here is staggering.
And it provides a good exercise
opportunity for our teams
that are at the site.
They can just jog
around the perimeter
and do about almost three
miles of jogging just
to go around the
buildings right now.
So you've got the
what you need, you've
got the where you need
it, but what about how?
Well, you need it
available all the time.
If you caught the keynote
this morning by Urs,
he mentioned that
unsolicited by Google,
not commissioned by us at all,
but an independent industry
analyst said that,
by far, Google Cloud
has the lowest downtime of any
of the major cloud providers.
That's not by accident.
It's because of the
way that we design,
build, and operate
our data centers.
And when we say 7 by 24 by
365, we really mean that.
The design principle of our data
centers is to be fault tolerant
and allow us to maintain the
data centers transparent to all
of you.
What that means is
that, look, you can
hope that things don't break.
But I'm here to tell
you, things break.
When they do break,
you shouldn't
care because it should
be transparent to you.
So that means we have
to do maintenance
and we have to do upgrades
and repairs while the data
center is still live.
So we build in the ability to,
one, make it fault tolerant,
and, two, make it
concurrently maintainable.
We also build in hooks.
I talked a little bit earlier
about our value of optionality.
What that means is that we
don't have a crystal ball.
I don't know exactly what we're
going to need from our data
center a few years from now.
I don't know what the latest
generation of platforms that
are going to be
developed are, but we
want to add in the hooks
that allow us to accommodate
for whatever our platform's
development team comes up with.
One example is when we built
our first data centers,
we didn't know about the TPU
systems that were developed
for our ML and AI applications.
However, we were able
to accommodate those,
and even the latest
generation that requires water
cooling at the chip level.
We were able to
accommodate that because we
had built in the hooks to allow
us to do those types of things
in the future.
So really what the idea
there is that we're
looking to the future
and we're planning
to be able to accommodate
whatever the requirements are.
And from our operations team,
one of our core principles
is on continuous learning,
continuous improvement.
And what that means
is transparency.
If you make a mistake
you can't hide it.
People make mistakes.
It's OK.
We have a no blame policy,
because we just want
to learn from what happened.
And it's typical in the
industry that of all the data
center failures, still about
70% of all data center failures
today are related to
some form of human error.
At Google, ours are much less.
It's a little bit over
15% that are related
to some sort of human error.
However, because of
our designs, because we
don't expect perfection,
we design for them
to be tolerant of mistakes.
And what that means is
that even though there
were 15% of the errors that
were human-related, none of them
resulted in downtime
of the data centers.
That's also quite different
from the industry average.
In order to help our teams
manage the data centers,
we have to monitor everything.
You might say that we're a
little bit data obsessed.
So we're monitoring every
aspect of the data centers,
from the servers themselves,
monitoring temperatures and air
pressures and flow rates.
And in the mechanical
cooling yard,
the flow rates and
differential pressures
of the cooling systems.
On the electrical
side, everything
from the high voltage substation
all the way down to the server
level is monitored.
And of course, security.
All of our security systems,
all of our multi-layer security
systems.
So these are all monitored.
Truly, we have
world-class monitoring,
from chip all the
way to chiller.
And that enables our
teams to understand
what's going on so that they
can best operate, maintain,
and repair the data centers.
Speaking of security,
data centers
have to be ultra secure.
And ours are ultra secure.
There was a recent
CBRE study that
said that still one of the
highest priorities in site
selection for where to place
their equipment in a data
center is based on the security
profile of the data center.
So we take that very seriously.
We employ a
defense-in-depth type
of a strategy for physical
security at the data centers.
That means that from the
very outer perimeter,
around a campus that's
hundreds of acres large,
there's already barriers and
fencing to prevent people
from just wandering in.
And the closer you get to
the data center itself,
the higher the security, the
more rigid the policies are.
And what all this means is
that out of all the data
centers around the world,
less than 2% of Googlers
have ever set foot in
one of our data centers.
And that's done by
design, because protecting
the data and the information
and the privacy of our users
is at the foremost of our design
criteria for the data center.
So unless you have a job that
requires you to be at the data
center to perform that job, you
don't go to the data centers.
It's just that strict.
So I talked about our
physical security.
But truly, physical security
and information security
have to go hand-in-hand.
It's part of the
same design criteria.
However, our information
security team
are separate from my team.
And that is done by
design because, one,
they truly are the
world's experts
in protecting
information security.
It's a very large team.
They've been published
and written books
on security principles
and all that.
And truly, they need
to be standalone.
And it's also for
governance because you
want the two teams
to be little checks
and balances on each other.
So as I said on the
physical security side,
we use a multi-layered
strategy to get
into the data center itself.
You have to have a badge that
authorizes you to be there.
And that's tied to your
credentials, of course.
Then we have biometric
authentication,
which is pretty typical.
But then we have a lot of
other layers of security
that are not seen.
So we know who is in the
data centers, where they are.
We know what they've
touched, why they
did it, what actions they took.
So that we have complete
end-to-end traceability
of everything that's
happening in the data centers.
This is a quote from
Data Center Knowledge.
Basically, it's just
summarizing what
I've been saying is that data
center security measures are
built into pretty much every
single layer of the system,
from the data center itself,
the building, the security
principles, the security
designs, all the way down
to the servers themselves.
And our custom security chip
is built into the servers.
Now we know what you want, what
you need from a data center.
We know how you need
it, where you need it.
So we've covered
most of the reasons.
But what if you could
wrap all this up
with sustainability also?
More and more, our
customers are telling us
that they have their
own corporate mandates
around sustainability and
energy use and renewable energy
purchases.
So we have been focused
on sustainability for long
before I came to Google.
We were the first company
to achieve a zero carbon
footprint.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
But really, our
sustainability efforts
are broken into three
pillars, if you will.
Energy efficiency.
Because truly, the
best use of energy
is the energy you don't
use in the first place.
So we've been laser focused
on energy efficiency
at the data centers.
Second, our use of
renewable energy to power
the data centers.
I'll get into a lot
more detail about that.
And lastly, our commitment
to a circular environment,
and our philosophy of a
zero waste to landfill.
And I'll talk more
about that as well.
So as I said, the
best energy saved
is the energy not consumed
in the first place.
Google data centers
are without a doubt
some of the most
efficient in the world.
What that means is that compared
to a traditional enterprise
data center, a Google data
center consumes about half
of the energy that a traditional
enterprise data center would.
And at the same time,
we're delivering
seven times more compute
power at our data centers
today than we were
just five years ago.
So what that means
is that that's
a lot more Gmail, a lot more
search, a lot more YouTube cat
videos, and a lot bigger
cloud for the same energy
footprint as just
a few years ago.
As a matter of fact, one
measure of energy efficiency
in the data centers is a very
simple metric called PUE.
Most of you have
probably heard of it,
it's a very simple ratio.
It's the total energy consumed
at the data center divided
by the IT energy used.
And so everything
else is overhead.
So it's a ratio that generally
measures something above 1.
And most average data
centers are still about 1.58.
What that means is that
they have 58% overhead.
Our data centers
have 11% overhead.
And this is a trailing
12-month average
across the fleet of every
single one of our data centers
around the world.
This is not cherry picked, this
is not our best data center,
this is across the entire fleet.
And it's been that
way for a long time.
But we didn't just rest on
making energy efficient data
centers and building energy
efficient computing systems,
we then decided to try and
make better use of the data
that we're getting
from our data centers.
One of our engineers
came up with the idea
that said, if we could build
a machine learning algorithm
to analyze these volumes of data
that we're gathering everyday
at the data centers, maybe we
could find some insights that
would help us drive the energy
efficiency even further.
That's exactly what he did.
And then he partnered
with our DeepMind group
to basically make it
production-worthy.
We employed that.
And now we have
the full ML system
operating parts of
our cooling systems
at the data center fully
autonomously, very safely.
And of the energy
consumption for the cooling,
we've achieved about a 30%
reduction in the energy
consumption for
cooling by having
the ML system operate the data
center cooling system for us.
The way it does that,
it's very simple.
It's looking at about 19
to 20 independent variables
in real time.
And it's matching the cooling
needs to the data center
load at that time.
So it's doing it in real time,
and it's constantly adjusting.
And this is basically
far more efficient
than humans could do it.
And so we developed it, we
tested it over many years.
And little by little, we
made it fully autonomous.
So now, it's controlling
the data center cooling.
As I talked about, we
have a strong commitment
to powering the data
centers on renewable energy.
So we started our renewable
energy and our zero carbon
journey roughly
in about 2007 when
we decided that as a company
we were going to achieve a zero
carbon footprint.
And we did achieve that in
2007, and we did that primarily
by buying very high
quality carbon offsets.
So we were just offsetting
our carbon footprint.
And we did that for 10 years.
And in 2017, apart from
celebrating the 10 year
anniversary of being a
carbon neutral company,
we also announced
that we had achieved
another major milestone.
And that was that we are now
buying enough renewable energy
to offset the entire consumption
of energy at Google data
centers and Google overall,
the entire enterprise.
What does that mean?
That means that we are
the world's largest
corporate purchaser
of renewable energy.
We have since 2000--
roughly 10-ish-- we have signed
over 30 large scale power
purchase agreements for
solar and wind energy.
That is over three
and 1/2 gigawatts
of energy under contract.
So we are now matching.
For every kilowatt or
megawatt hour of energy
we consume around
all of Google, we
are now buying at least an equal
amount of renewable energy.
And we are the first
company of our size
to ever achieve 100%
matching of our consumption
versus renewable.
This is a little
bit of our journey
when we started in 2007.
Frankly, I should have
put on this slide when
I was just saying all that
stuff, but anyhow, like I said,
we now have over three and
1/2 gigawatts under contract.
We've spent over $5 billion
on these energy purchase
agreements.
In 2017, as I mentioned,
we had 10 consecutive years
of carbon neutrality.
And we matched 100%
of our consumption.
But as I talked about, we
don't rest on our laurels.
And so even that is
not good enough for us.
Because in order for us to
truly take responsibility
for our energy
footprint and our impact
to the environment
and the climate,
we need to be able
to match our energy
consumption with
renewable energy 24 hours
a day, seven days a week.
As you know, some of the
grids in which we operate
don't have abundant
renewable energy on them.
In some places, the
regulatory environment
doesn't allow you to
go out and purchase
your own renewable
energy contracts.
So in order to
achieve that, we're
going to have to come up
with some creative thinking.
So the team has been doing that.
And one of the
demonstrations of this
is that in Taiwan, where
the regulatory environment
previously had not allowed
corporate companies
to go out and buy their
own energy contracts,
and put it on the
grid there in Taiwan.
So we worked with the Taiwan
power company and the Taiwan
national government.
And over a period of time
of collaborating with them,
we were able to get the
Taiwan Power Act changed
that allows us to buy
renewable energy contracts
and put it on the
grid in Taiwan.
So our first one that
we did is pretty unique.
These are fish ponds
where they fish farm,
they raise fish in
these ponds, right?
So we have a developer that
is now building solar panels
above these fish ponds.
So now we have a solar pond, or
a solar farm above a fish farm.
And it's right in
the same local area
as where our data center is.
So that is helping us to
green our operations in Taiwan
and helping us basically
take more accountability
for our consumption
in that local region.
So this is the first
of a kind in Taiwan.
And by the way, when we
make these agreements,
we don't do it just for us.
We make the policy
so that anyone
that wants to follow our
actions can do that also.
Another example.
In Belgium, we did
this solar farm.
This is about
10,000 solar panels
on our data center property.
Normally, we would
do these off-site
where we could have
larger installations.
But in this case,
this was a great way
to match or offset our energy
consumption for our office
areas and our facilities.
Not the data center itself,
that would be too large.
However, in another part in
the southeast of the United
States in Tennessee
and Alabama, we
worked with the Tennessee
Valley Authority
to build one of the largest
PPAs is that has ever
been done in that region.
That's 1.5 million solar
panels, 413 megawatts
that are being
built specifically
for Google that will offset
our consumption in that region
for the foreseeable future.
So we're going to have to
work hard to actually make
this a reality, 24 by
7 renewable energy.
As you know, like I
said, renewable energy
is not available
everywhere in the world.
It's not available every day
or every hour of the day.
The sun doesn't
shine 24 hours a day.
The wind doesn't
blow 24 hours a day.
So we're going to have to
get very creative with this.
We've developed a
tool that allows
us to analyze at a
data center level
the consumption
of the data center
and match it to what the
renewable energy generation is,
hour-for-hour, so that we
can see how we're doing.
In some data centers in
parts of the world where
we don't have a lot of
access to renewable energy,
it's not matched very well yet.
In other parts, we're over
65% matching today already.
So we have a long
way to go, but we
think it's important enough to
dedicate a team of resources
to this initiative.
And it's a long-term goal.
I don't know when we're
going to achieve it.
It is arguably a moonshot.
Typical Google thinking.
But in order to really
take accountability
for our footprint, this
is what we have to do.
As I mentioned, this happens
to be the data center
in North Carolina showing how
on a day, hour-by-hour basis,
we're matching with
our renewable energy.
So you can see that in
some parts of the year,
we are 82% carbon-free.
Other parts of the year,
we're 49% carbon-free.
So it changes, of course,
seasonally, and hour by hour.
But this is giving us the
insights that we need.
The really cool
thing that we did--
remember that ML
system I told you
about that was operating our
data center cooling systems?
Well, DeepMind and us partnered
together to adjust that system
and said, what if we apply
that same type of machine
learning to a wind farm.
What would that do?
Well, we developed
jointly a new ML system
that allows us to predict what
the energy generation of a wind
farm will be 36
hours in advance.
Why is that really important?
Because if you're
a grid operator,
the intermittency of
renewables make it really hard
for you to plan how much
generation you need.
You know what your
demand is going
to be more or less
because you've
got a long history of
looking at your demand
from your customers.
But you don't know what the
output of that wind farm
is going to be tomorrow.
Well, this ML system
allows us to predict it
with a high degree of
fidelity what it is.
So now they can plan
on that and put that
into their baseload
calculations.
We can better utilize the full
output of the wind farm, which
has resulted-- now
this is the early days,
I don't know if this is
going to be how it is always,
I hope it's better.
But we've already achieved
about a 20% improvement
in the value of the
wind farm that this
was done at, the value
of that renewable energy.
So I think there's
a lot of hope here.
And the third pillar is
the circular economy.
And our belief is that we should
reuse and recycle and have
a zero waste to landfill goal.
We have achieved zero
waste to landfill
at some of our data centers,
but not all of them.
Today, across the
entire portfolio
we're 91% diversion
of waste to landfill.
That means that only
9% of all of our waste,
whether it's from
construction or operations,
is making it to a landfill.
This required us to think
about things differently,
to come up with better
reuse strategies
so that we can take
components that maybe
aren't used for that
particular customer,
but use them for another
internal customer.
Like for instance,
if Search said
those machines are
out of date for us,
but some of our other internal
services can still use them.
So rather than
just recycle them,
we're reusing a lot of that.
We're remanufacturing
a lot of our servers
with recycled components.
And we're reselling
some of our components
as well so that we're
really diverting
a lot of that otherwise
would be electronic waste.
And it's not just
us talking about it,
but a lot of other people have
noticed our sustainability
efforts.
So we've been at the top of the
CDP awards list for many years.
We were given the Zayed Future
Energy Award in Abu Dhabi
a couple of years ago.
So it's being noticed.
It's not just we're
doing it for ourselves,
but we're doing it for all
of you, all of our customers
as well, because now you know
that the workloads that you run
in Google Cloud are helping you
achieve your own sustainability
and your own carbon
neutrality initiatives.
This is a quote here from
one of our customers, Etsy,
their CTO said that underneath
their ecological goal
they want to be 100%
renewable electricity by 2020.
And that they know that
all of their workloads
that they're processing
with us on Google Cloud
are helping them to achieve
this initiative because they
are already being powered by
renewable energy on our cloud.
So if we review our
core principles,
our core principles for
our data center program
are around performance,
availability, reliability,
security, and an
environmental responsibility,
and a commitment to
100% sustainability.
We truly are building the
world's most sustainable cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]